dans le nord et le pas-de-calais
l'industrie représentait plus de six
cent quarante mille emplois en 1954 -
285000 en 2018
que s'est il passé retour sur la
désindustrialisation du nord de la
france dans quatre secteurs symbolique
jusque dans les années 1950 le nord est
un moteur industriel grâce à ses mines
de charbon notamment
mais un long déclin s'amorce avec la
concurrence du pétrole et du gaz et en
1968 ces gueules noires vive la fin
d'une époque
leurs mines vient de fermer il
s'inquiète pour l'avenir et on se
demande qu'est ce qu'on va faire de nos
enfants bien rien de prévu pour les
causes et quiches et qui est responsable
de tout genre j'ai lu au terme d'un
échange mais on aurait dû prévenir du
boulot pour les jeunes
on ne réduit implanter des usines tout
très réduite l'activité charbonnière
cessera définitivement en 1990
[Musique]
dans les années 70 c'est la révolte des
sidérurgistes qui fait grand bruit
le secteur est à son tour rattrapé par
la crise en cause la concurrence
internationale qui aura raison de la
plupart des hauts fourneaux français en
lorraine et dans le nord comme ici à
denain en 1980 c'est fini
c'est notre dernier jour aujourd'hui à
tout le monde oui et donc ici ensemble
pour la dernière fois avec les deux
fourneaux j'ai 29 ans et je décidais
creuser
en 1954 le textile est le premier
pourvoyeur d'emplois dans la région
son emblème c'est la lainière à roubaix
à un fleuron que l'on présente fièrement
à la reine d'angleterre lors de sa
visite dans le nord en 1957
mais en 2007 même usine ferme
définitivement ses portes après 88 ans
d'activité avec un salaire de 50 ans la
ligne r c'était mon travail c'était ma
vie tout mon mari aussi
on était à deux dans la lumière comme
beaucoup d'entre nous d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est l'industrie du pneu
fier gravement touché à béthune
l'usiné bridgestone installé depuis 1961
est menacée de fermeture
une actualité qui rappelle les
événements chez goodyear en 2014 ou
encore la colère des employés de
continental dans l'oise qui en désespoir
de cause sa cage la sous préfecture de
compiègne en avril 2009
j'ai honte j'ai vraiment honte monsieur
sarkozy peut-être française quand on
voit ce qui se passe à quelle heure
actuelle qu'on va peut-être que votre
travail crois tu es plus avoir d'argent
pour payer nos factures
c'est inadmissible au premier trimestre
2009 1 le taux de chômage dans les hauts
de france s'élève à 9,6 pour cent soit 2
points au-dessus de la moyenne nationale
[Musique]